without you and queen Idina elsa and
anna wouldn't be who they are today but
we'd be lying if we said we weren't
curious about you and I do his past and
what happened after the fog barrier went
up we know that I do not risk everything
to save you and that the spirits
rewarded her by giving her a magical
daughter but we want to know so much
more how did you guys fall in love how
did you react when I do not told you the
truth about her heritage and be honest
Agner did you know about while your
father was planning to do we have so
many questions about the former king and
queen of arendelle
but unlike Elsa we can't dive into the
river full of memory and uncovered the
truth about the past Agner and I do not
totally deserve their own movie and
we're about to tell you why so stay
tuned once stood an enchanted forest it
was a magical place but something went
wrong since then no one can get in or
out if there's one thing we know for
sure it's that Elsa and Anna's father
was a super nice guy
sure Agner his father was pretty evil
but his wicked ways managed to skip a
generation Agner had no idea about his
father's double-crossing ways this is
made obvious by how shocked he was when
the fight between the arendelle soldiers
and the North Olga try broke out if it
hadn't been for I dunno sacrifice Agner
would never have made it out of the
forest alive Agner was an only child and
his mother wasn't in the picture so on
the night that his father betrayed the
tribe and was pushed off a cliff Agner
took over as the king of arendelle
actor's father was terrified of magic
whereas Agner was intrigued by it when
he saw I do enough floating around with
Gale the wind spirit he couldn't believe
his eyes he was drawn to Oona and the
people of the enchanted forest
but his outlook changed when Elsa's ice
powers almost cost him Anna and frozen
instead of consoling Elsa who was
clearly terrified Agra rushed on aside
and asked Elsa what have you done and
that's when the panic settled in he told
Elsa that her powers were getting out of
hand
AG nerudin understand Elsa's abilities
and people fear what they don't
understand that's what led him to teach
Elsa to conceal don't feel which wasn't
exactly the best advice over time Agner
began to resent Elsa's powers causing
Elsa to see them as a curse and not a
gift
[Music]
what's going on I think I woke the
magical spirit of the enchanted forest
okay that's definitely not what I
thought you were gonna say Queen I
Doudna grew up in the enchanted forest
so she knew better than anyone that
magic was a beautiful thing she was
friends with the spirits and immediately
took a liking to Agner who was of
similar age as her when the fight broke
loose
I dunno didn't hesitate to save Agner
she left her family behind and escaped
with nothing but the scarf on her back
literally later in life she would coddle
the scarf whenever the going got rough
and eventually she passed it down to her
daughters if it hadn't been for this
scarf Yelena would never have accepted
an ax and also with open arms
according to Yelena the scarf belonged
to one of the oldest families of the
myth older tribe but this is virtually
the only thing we know about I Dunas
pass so we're left wondering if she has
any living relatives of her own we'd
love to know if I do they belong to a
royal family or anything else for a
matter of fact one of the many reasons
why I do none Agner need their own movie
has everything to do with their love
story and the big question mark that
surrounds it and frozen too we see a
short scene of I do know and Agner
meeting for the first time Agner is
reading under a tree and I do know
surprises him asking him what he's
reading but besides the small snippet we
don't really know anything about how
these two fell in love I do know would
go on to become the queen of arendelle
and somewhere down the line she chose it
to Agner about her heritage she
confesses to being the one who saved him
but did this happen before after they
got married and how did aDNA react we
want answers Disney
aggghhhhh nur and Idina story ends in a
very tragic way and then frozen - we
finally find out the truth about their
whereabouts
I do not and Agner we're journeying
across a dark sea to answer Holland they
wanted to find out the origins of Elsa's
powers since they were growing every day
and also was suffering in solitude
before Elsa accidentally froze on his
head she was allowed to use her powers
at will and she was happy it must have
been super hard for Agner and I do now
to see also grow ashamed of her powers
especially since they couldn't do
anything to help her AG nur and I do not
wanted to give their daughter her life
back so they took a major risk but it
wasn't only about Elsa I do nan ogner
also wanted to bring down the fog and
rescue the people who were trapped in
the enchanted forest and I do now must
have been desperate to reconnect with
her family and all the people she left
behind unfortunately I do Anna a nag
never reach on to Holland or find the
answers they were looking for Disney
fans are curious to find out about AG
Marin Adina's last voyage but most
importantly they're interested in
uncovering the truth about their pasts
so much was left to the imagination
every single scene that involved Elsa
and on his parents was super
entertaining and intriguing they totally
deserve their own movie why do you think
I do and I risked everything to save a
boy she didn't even know if you love all
things Disney subscribe to the things we
post weekly Theory videos about your
favorite Disney Princesses so click that
Bell and turn on those notifications if
you're watching on your phone turn all
notifications and your YouTube settings
so you never miss another video and
that's a wrap on why Anna and Elsa's
parents deserve their own movie which
other Disney parents are you interested
in hearing about sound off in the
comments thanks for watching don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up we'll catch you next time on the
things